now
i feel like i've
i've drank the lava of mount doom
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by elijah wood he's
been in more than 60 films over the
course of his more than 30 year long
acting career from academy award-winning
indies to one of the highest grossing
box office film franchises of all time
his latest project though is no man of
god which is set to release in select
theaters and on demand august 27th
elijah wood welcome to the show thank
you so much for having me this is a real
honor and you know i've heard this story
second hand but i'd like to just bring
it to you directly okay so as i
understand it you're doing an interview
or a podcast on this floor in this
building yes see the hot one sauce is on
display and you're like out of curiosity
i'd like to try those out is that more
or less how the adventure starts and
then where does it go from there more or
less uh yes i didn't realize that hot
ones was filmed in this particular
location so when i got here i was like
oh [ __ ] i've always wanted to be on the
show man that'd be amazing and they're
like well if you want to try some of the
the hot sauces just as like a separate
little like internet bit we can do that
i was like sure let's do that and so we
tried a couple of sauces including this
one here the bun i'm very familiar with
this
the friend and colleague who i was with
tim league who created the alamo
drafthouse theater which you may know he
then has a very severe reaction to this
sauce to which we the ambulance was
called
i'm outside my friend's doing better
having a conversation with some of the
people that work on the floor and i
start to get this warm sensation in my
stomach that just continues to grow and
grow and grow and i thought oh [ __ ] and
this is it and i ended up also on my
knees in a severe amount of pain well
respect for coming back to try it again
elijah are you ready to get started yes
[Music]
almost fantastic
heat with heart it says
that's great i mean that's a
that's warm
it's nice
so your new film no man of god
chronicles the interviews between serial
killer ted bundy and fbi agent bill
hagmeyer who is credited with coaxing
the criminal confession out of the
campus killer
thinking back on the real-life
consultations that you actually had with
the real bill hagmaier what interested
you most about the chemistry or the
psychological interplay between fbi
agent and serial killer oh man i think
the ability to be in a room with someone
like that and find their humanity to a
degree so it's it's one thing to go into
that room
looking for information from a
psychological standpoint which is what
bill was doing but it's another thing
entirely to also see that person as
another human which he also had to do in
order to have those interactions for ted
to feel safe to be able to express and
sort of reveal the things that he needed
him to reveal we know a lot about ted
that was a thing i didn't know i didn't
realize that there was this agent that
had spent this kind of time with him
over the course of the four years prior
to his death yeah like
like calling him his best friend and
stuff like that ted literally said that
he was his best friend and i think you
know for ted the reason why he
considered bill his best friend is that
unlike other fbi agents and law
enforcement whom he didn't trust
it's because those guys had an agenda
more often than not he assumed that they
would go off and write a book about
their conversations
bill never did and i think that's why he
he trusted him and why he considered him
a friend at the end because he didn't
come in with an agenda he really wanted
to understand
well that's nice
artisanal chili sauce
so beyond the frozen pizza aisle i know
that you're somewhat of a gourmand and
you're oftentimes taking pictures of
ramen and then researching the
restaurant scene fanatically wherever
you go yes if you had a food obsessive
visiting you in austin what would be the
most mouth-watering itinerary you could
put together like the best breakfast
lunch and dinner move you could make in
that city breakfast tacos
um at el primo
which is a taco truck on um
south 1st street near mary
pizza via 313 for lunch it's probably my
favorite pizza in the world it's a
detroit style pizza it is exceptional
and then dinner
ramen tatsu is incredible uh that would
be a great one their shoyu ramen is
amazing the tonkatsu is incredible and
they have
a slider that is a pork katsu slider
that is
the stuff of dreams
it it honestly if i could eat one every
day i would it's a it's a pork katsu
very small it's on a little little
slider bun
with um a kind of coleslaw and it's just
phenomenal do you have an all-time
favorite elijah wood movie scene
involving food the hot sauce and lime
scene in the trust is you know
special for me personally that's a very
good one that's a very good one
involving food i i mean you've sort of
stolen it that's a great one that's a
great one for a couple of reasons one
it's opposite opposite nicolas cage
which
was for me
the first time as an actor genuinely
that i had an out-of-body experience
working with another actor and i
remember being in scenes conversing with
him and he would say something to me and
i would think in my brain as i'm acting
opposite him oh my god that's nickage
the way he said that was like so like
nick cage oh my god
so
one of my favorite experiences as an
actor was working opposite him he was a
delight and to get to see his creative
process was a joy um and that scene is
hilarious so yeah i i i'm sorry i don't
have a better answer you really kind of
made the answer perfect
[Music]
oh intensely spicy just one drop hot
sauce
[ __ ] that's good
way more awesome very good wings
shout out shorties hey shorties
it's your birthday
so at this point i know that you've done
more than your fair share of necropsies
surrounding lord of the rings but on
this wing what we want to do is fact
check some of the fables that have made
their way onto internet message boards
and into the headlines and just fact
check them somebody with somebody who
has boots on the ground great
is it true that after winning 11 oscars
at the academy awards in 2002 you
director peter jackson and the crew
ditched the traditional post-show
celebrations to instead go to a lord of
the rings fan party that was put on by
the one ring website correct
yeah we went around to a couple of
parties and then we ended up there and
spent the majority of our evening at the
onering.net party it was truly the end
of the journey for us
being able to then go back and celebrate
with the fans was the only thing to do
and nothing against the vanity fair
party and those sort of you know events
they're fun but this was like it didn't
have any of the pressure or the fanfare
we could just hang out it was really
nice it was really nice maybe you're
privy to this maybe you're not is there
any truth to peter jackson orchestrating
twenty thousand cricket fans between
inning breaks to put on the sounds of
the yurakai army whoa
is that a thing
i don't i don't know if that's true it
would most likely be rugby cause rugby
is really the game in new zealand and
new zealand i mean they do play cricket
but
i feel like the rugby crowd is a far
more boisterous crowd than cricket i
would have thought
but i could be wrong i've never been to
a cricket game it's a weird one isn't
that it goes on for days
goes on for days and sometimes it's a
tie and no one wins
three [ __ ] days
and then finally is it true that you let
out the fart heard round the shire doing
a hillside roll with your hobbit cast
first day of filming
day one uh so yeah we're in the scene is
um we are rolling down the hill after uh
mary and pippen run into us running away
from farmer maggots field having stolen
a bunch of vegetables they
bang into us we roll down the hill
so it's picking up that moment of
falling down the hill and
falling on top of each other in a very
comedic way
and i think it was like take two and i i
had a a
a can what is that a a concussion fart a
fart that is uh brought on by pressure
and yeah i literally fell
and everybody burst out laughing it was
great it was very funny
[Music]
it's a hell of a way to start filming
lord of the rings you got to announce
your presence somehow i have to say all
of these have been delicious that one
has a kind of sweetness to it
and a little barbecuey sort of flavor to
it a kind of smoky barbecue that's what
we're that's what we're going for kind
of like a summer sauce like a slow
roasted meats or like like grilled
vegetables kind of hot sauce that's
great love that one
so you're the voice of spyro the dragon
likewise made an appearance in god of
war a few years ago were hand selected
by microsoft to unveil the xbox 360.
as a video game obsessive and someone
who i'm sure thinks about these sorts of
things
is there a game that you think is
especially ripe for a screenplay
adaptation the universe of gta lends
itself beautifully to a screen
adaptation or a tv show um
i mean i think vice city could be
amazing although that already is sort of
inspired by miami vice
but gta 5
i mean the kinds of characters that are
present within the context of that game
very much lends itself either to a film
or a tv series that would be amazing
another thing that's happening in the
world of video games in terms of
adaptations is they're going back to um
resident evil yeah and i'm very keen on
that because the the original resident
evil whether it's your thing or not is
very different from the game from an
aesthetic standpoint it was always a
shame to me that they didn't lean on the
sort of world that had been established
in the game and i think that's coming up
which i'm very excited about well you
know speaking of that you know games
like silent hill or resident evil
sometimes they can be a more frightening
experience than even the most
suspenseful thrillers totally like
psychologically what do you think that
they can do that maybe films aren't able
to
well it it's an immersive experience um
unlike a film which is passive you are a
participant in the game
you're playing the character
there are moments playing sequels of
silent hill that were genuinely
disturbing to play you're not sitting
back and watching something you are
making the choice to go down that
hallway you are making the choice to you
know what i mean and i think in that
sense there's a there's a level of
suspense and sort of within the context
of the interactivity that makes it maybe
more scary
[Music]
all right ginger goat the original goat
yeah i feel like the habanero like
kicked us into gear and then we've kind
of been coasting a little bit yeah the
the three in this season
is a little jarring and then it does
downshift a little bit it's nice though
but it's about to kick back up enjoy
that feeling while you can right
great i'm not gonna i don't need water
yet i'm all right all right elijah we
have a crane segment on our show called
explain that graham we're doing a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so we'll show you the pictures
over here on the monitor you just tell
us the bigger story
and in preparing for this interview i
read a little bit about forced
perspective and motion controlled camera
range
can you give us one piece of cinematic
wizardry that really blew your mind when
you actually saw it in action onset
thousand percent so there's a scene at
the back end kitchen table
and it was split um into two pieces
where
he was um ian mckellen as gandalf was
sitting at one
portion of the table and i was sitting
at another portion of the table
and
scale appropriate elements were at
either table and the table would move
along with the camera to make sure that
the angle was always appropriate to make
him look like he was sitting in front of
me and i was sitting opposite him and
i'd look at a tennis ball so anytime ian
was talking to me and we're having the
scene play out and we're talking to each
other
i'm looking there and he is looking
opposite him at a tennis ball
and in camera it looks like we're
sitting opposite each other and he looks
giant and i look small and that was
incredible and there was also the cart
so when i jump into the cart at the very
beginning of the film when when
gandalf's coming into the shire for the
first time and
you know you're late and the wizard's
never late uh they've arrived precisely
when they mean to frodo jumps into his
arms and then they're sitting opposite
or they're sitting side by side
going through having a conversation
about you know bilbo's party and so on
and so forth and that was a similar
thing i was sitting behind him and he
was sitting in front of me and the
camera was set at such an angle we were
going back to real basics in regards to
the magic of cinema it was awesome we
also had scale doubles so for any wide
shots
there would be
there were um people that we had um uh
many of them that were that size so
about
three foot eight three foot six um that
would be our doubles for anything wide
and they would wear masks that would
have like your face a silicon mask with
our face but the mat the masks wouldn't
move
excuse me so that was a bit jarring
because you would see someone walking
around with your face but it was
inanimate it was just
in a fixed position
made in tucson
the old tucks in arizona
oh there we go
yeah there is a bit of like a hot curry
vibe
oh yeah and the um
the peppers are
sitting right on top
pretty hot as well oh that's good
so i know that you have a deep
connection to scary movies it's a hobby
that began when you were a child and
then it's grown into you co-founding
spectrovision in 2010 a production
company that focuses on horror movies
what can you tell people about truth or
dare a critical madness
sir you've done your research um
truth or dare critical madness it's one
of the first horror movies i remember
seeing
it's a great and the movie is about a
guy who who's uh at the very beginning
of the movie he catches his wife
sleeping with his best friend
uh and colleague
um and then he he freaks out has a
pretty traumatic reaction to it and
leaves in a huff
and then he goes on this road trip and
loses his mind and he he uh picks up a
hitchhiker
and she says would you like to play
truth or dare and he's like yeah okay
truth or dare all right play truth or
dare and it goes from like throw your
wallet in the fire you know uh pretty
intense thing but all right he's you
know he's on this journey
to
cut your tongue out
it's sublime it's so great the
performances are not good
it's just
i'm i got a warm hug all over right now
it's great
so this is really fun you're having a
good time i'm loving this
all right number seven
i'm waiting for you man all right all
right
i'm in yeah of course
[Music]
oh sure
oh man when you get to that level
that kind of like i know that i know
that flavor
i know what's up i know it's about to
happen
yeah i know exactly what you're saying
by that like i'll know when something's
a super hot 1000 second i smell yeah
yeah the scent and that first
yeah that first taste on your taste buds
wow that's good man
that's good now we're now we're cooking
with gas yeah
there we go
i'm always curious with an actor who's
as prolific as you are is there an under
the radar project that when a fan brings
it up to you on the street it maybe hits
you emotionally a little bit differently
yes that is such a great question by the
way that is not something that i hear
often
but it is in relation to a reaction that
i often have which is
when someone brings something up that
isn't as common as say lord of the rings
which is obviously the most common thing
uh there's a couple um
over the garden wall
is a big one um there's an animated mini
series on a cartoon network this sort of
beautiful 2d animation style that feels
very much like it evokes something from
the past
it's really stunning
grand piano that still remains one of my
favorite experiences working on a film
and
on the production side of things
uh i get really excited when people uh
reference the greasy strangler because
that is not something that many people
have seen
and it's a polarizing movie it's a movie
not for everyone and so when people are
enthusiastic and have seen the movie i
get very excited because i think it's
incredible you recognize that wavelength
it's a specific wavelength
and i am very much on that wavelength
all right
it is that time oh [ __ ] all right here
we go back
all right tim league this one's for you
avenging yep
okay
[Music]
there's a sort of dryness to it
it sort of feels like someone's dusted
it with hots that's a good way to put it
because that's how i feel
right now i think i inhaled
just the right way oh and just yeah
caught like a pepper buck shot
right in the ass oh yeah i mean i
definitely had yeah
right in the back
well just
this is gonna suck later it really is
so i know that you have a passion for
music
djing for more than 10 years and over
that time built up a massive vinyl
collection
what's the last retro 45 that you bought
off ebay
um
i'll tell you what
the hot sauce really [ __ ] with your
brain it does and it's capability of
being able to answer which is really a
clever aspect of the show
see what you've done here
um
yeah you've really kept the interview on
its toes
um
the last 45 that i bought was actually a
kanye west 45 wash is in the blood
that's the name of the song wow that is
really [ __ ] hot
that's
it's weird because i've had that before
but maybe not so much
i think i only had like a little dab
last time this is a whole wing it's like
what's fascinating what's happening
right now is that it actually
i feel like the capillaries in my face
are on fire and maybe that's also
because i touched my face with that yeah
i think i did two
around my nose we're suffering together
in this how about oh yeah of all the
original impressions that you own wow
which one required the most time and
effort to track down
there's a 45 from a welsh band called
bran
it's like a psychedelic welsh brand
band that i've had a difficulty tracking
down and that's very good
i have that now
wow
yeah
and that's not even the end
that's great
this is great
but this is why we do this you know we
go this is why we go through it yeah
the experience
well
i may have i may not have actually
physically thrown a ring into
mount doom
but
now
i feel like i've
i've drank the lava of mount doom
[Music]
apologize there's so many burps
yeah i mean once you've like
destroyed your mouth everything else
just like whatever
more of the same
you know you've lit the fire right
fire's going can't get hotter no it's an
inferno
so in 2006 you're ranked number seven
this is my favorite part of the show
it's like magazines
let's
let's try and let's try and
break synapses fire and communicate with
your mouth an autograph collector
magazines list yeah of the 10 best
hollywood autograph signers what's your
guiding philosophy when it comes to
dealing with the autographed hounds of
hollywood
this is so flattering um
with autograph hounds specifically yeah
oh bud that's a tough one
um
because there's a there's a separation
between
fans who genuinely genuinely want to
meet you and have an autograph
and then the people who collect it and
sell the photos i know what's going on
but
i can't bring myself to say no because i
don't want to be a dick
sometimes they they can make it
excuse me a bummer for fans
because they'll crowd a space and you
know if there's a if there's an event
that people know that they're going to
be there there's loads of fans but then
there's also tons of autograph hounds
that will have like multiples
and that can ruin it for people who
care um so that's kind of a bummer but
i'll always sign because i just you know
i like to be nice
it's hard for me to be a dick i don't
want to be a dick
all right elijah wood oh is this the
last down
[Music]
hey it's the last dab
this is a it was a hot session i feel
like
i'm i'm noticing i'm seeing you react
more than i feel like i've ever seen you
react which i'm honored
just for you elijah i'm honored just for
you oh did i do was that too much
someone just said oh god what did i do
what did i do yeah yeah
they've been we've seen it all before
okay
ready cheers cheers my friend nostrovia
[Music]
what's the story with the last dab
so
smoking ad oh is this a creation of his
yeah so this is made with pepper x which
is his next generation reaper but it's
just ad growing it on just this farm
he's a
madman we we got in with ed to get like
the pepper x and just make this sauce
with it
that's wrap so that's a little ass dab
yeah that's ram
that's um yeah man
[Laughter]
but again i think once once you're once
you're primed
i mean this is beautifully curated i
must say it's like
it's like a symphony you know starting
off really slow i mean maybe it's like a
little single cello
here
and then you just keep adding elements
and elements and this kind of there's a
ramp up i mean it's beautiful it's like
a conductor and this guy
i mean this is like
stravinsky comes in with the [ __ ] you
know what i mean it's intense
and but once once that starts i just
don't feel like
this was the absolute destroyer yeah
this is when things were brought to a
new level but i'm there now so i'm like
well [ __ ] whatever last time well you
know what i mean like you're primed
you're you're sort of it
i feel numb
elijah it's because you know maybe it's
because you see through
this whole thing but that really uh
connected with me really spoke to me
because that's what we try to do we
actually call it a spice symphony you do
yes
internally behind the scenes
and then the other thing about it is you
know we do think of it like a story arc
yeah like once we hit this we do want to
kind of
land it a little bit i don't even know
if
yeah oh man and this is a beautiful way
[Music]
this is a beautiful way to do that
this has been awesome
and we're not done yet
well you know what i had a question but
i don't even know if it's you know
because this was such a beautiful
conversation to encapsulate
the experience yeah that i almost want
to just like
snap it off right there for elijah wood
who's somebody who's who's seen the show
watched the show experienced a practice
run of the show yes and now
sitting down for the real thing yeah
this has been
really fun
and i am honored and i have been a long
time watcher and uh this is very cool
for me
this guy
old trusty forever the benchmark
in the show for years and it had to stay
here because it had to be here for you
elijah would thank you look at you
taking on the hot ones gauntlet
conquering it the second time around
this time with some steaks and a few
million witnesses and now elijah would
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you this camera this
camera this camera let the people know
what you have going on in your life um
well you can you can yeah you can go see
uh either in theaters um or on demand a
movie called no man of god about ted
bundy and his relationship to bill
hagmeyer the fbi agent
and i'm about to make a film uh with a
certain maken blair called the toxic
avenger
uh which will be super fun we work
together on a movie called i don't feel
at home in this world anymore which i i
adore uh and he is remaking uh toxic
avengers so we're about to go shoot them
camera guy bill i can't tell you how
hyped he is no i'm just talking about
that namaste this is awesome thank you
so much
it was really fun
thank you so much
is there someone that has anyone vomited
not like on set but we've had some
people like
where's the restroom like on cut or like
yeah whatever or like people are like i
need to take a break in the middle or
something like that and i don't know
what they do sure sure
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a quick
reminder of the hot ones season 15
sauces are currently available at
heatness.com that's right heatness.com
to get your hands on the season 15 hot
sauces i know you're sitting there
you're wondering at home like oh it
can't be that hot i think they're
overdoing it they're exaggerating i've
had spicy before i can do it well put it
to the test now available heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 15 hot sauces
be careful around the eyes
[Music]